خلال ثلاثه اشهر فقط ازال مركز اعتدال
اكثر من سته ملايين محتوى متطرف على منصه
تيليجرام حيث كشف تقرير للمركز العالمي
لمكافحه الفكر المتطرفه عن ازاله عشرات
الاف من المنشورات الداعيه للتطرف لعدد من
المنظمات الارهابيه وذلك بالتعاون مع منصه
تيليجرام خلال الربع الاول من العام
الجاري كما كشف المركز عن اغلاق حوالي
2000 قناه استخدمت في بث وترويج افكار
متطرفه تعود لتنظيمات داعش والقاعده وهيئه
تحرير الشم تمكنت مشاهدينا اعتدال من رصد
النشاط الرقمي المتطرف لتنظيمات الثلاث
باللغه العربيه على منصه تيليجرام حيث تمت
ازاله اكثر من مليونين و700 الف محتوى
متطرف يعود لهيئه تحرير الشام وحوالي
مليونير محتوى متطرف في اكثر من الف قناه
تعود لتنظيم داعش
لتنظيم القاعده الارهابي مشاهدينا اكثر من
مليونين واربعمائه الف محتوى متطرف التاسع
من يناير الماضي ووفق تقرير اعتدال شهد
اعلى نشاط لبث المحتويات المتطرفه عبر
التليجرام لتنظيمات الارهابيه الثلاثه حيث
تجاوز 400 الف محتوى متطرف خلال يوم واحد
فقط فيما سجل في السابع والعشرين من مارس
الماضي اعلى معدل لانشاء قنوات متطرفه
لتلك التنظيمات حيث وصل عددها لاكثر من
مئه قناه في يوم واحد التعاون المشترك بين
المركز العالمي لمكافحه الفكر المتطرف
ومنصه التيليجرام مشاهدينا يتواصل للعام
الثاني على التوالي ليصل عدد ما تم ازالته
من فبراير عام 20 22 حتى الايه لاكثر من
21 مليون محتوى متطرف كما تم اغلاق اكثر
من ثمانيه الاف600
قناه متطرفه